هيا انا سعيد
بالغائكم
هذا المساء
لكن بنلتقي في ظرف
عصيب وضع يعني اقل ما يوصف به في السودان
ان وضع كارثي
يلتغيكن اليوم بعد انا في يوم امس
ارسلتني لا
لخصت فيه
ثلاث رسائل
رساله الاولى
كانت لقياده
الجيش وقياده الدعم السريع
وطالبتهم في انه يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
فان هي حرب
المنتصر فيها خاسر
رساله ثانيه
كانت
للشعب السوداني
ناشدتهم في الحفاظ على التماسك والوحده
والرساله الثالثه والاخيره
كانت للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي
لمساعده
السودان والوقوف بجانبه في هذه المهنه
حقيقه
تابعتم امس واليوم
ما زالت
هذه الحرب
اللعينه
تقضي على الاخضر واليابس
ايضا
السبب الرئيسي
بعد نداء الامس
الذي جعلني التقى بكم هذا المساء
تتابعون الوضع
الانساني الكارثي في السودان
معاناه الانسان السوداني في ظل هذه الحرب
اصلا
المعاناه كانت موجوده
من اقتصاد
ونهار متدني
نقص في كل الاشياء في الغذاء في الدواء
تفاقم هذا الوضع بشكل اكبر تزل هذه الحرب
هنالك انقطاع مستمر
التيار الكهربائي المياه الى اخره
لذلك
انا ودت التقيكم اليوم
لاكرر ما قلته بالامس
يجب ان تقف هذه الحرب
اليوم قبل غدا
لاتاحه الفرصه
للشعب السوداني بكل مكوناته
ليعود
لمسار الانتقال الذي بدا
من اكثر ما من ثلاثه سنوات
ايضا لن امر تكرار
يظل السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
المتاح للشعب السوداني
لتفادي الانزلاق
للحرب الاهليه
كلنا تابعنا
مالات الحرب الاهليه في مناطق كثيره من
اقليمنا في العالم العربي والافريقي
يجب ان نتفادى ذلك وما زالت الفرصه متاحه
لتفادى هذا الوضع الكارث
لذلك نطالب
بوقف فوري
اطلاق النار
والوصول لتفهمات تؤدي الى الوقف الدائم
للعادات
في اقل تقدير يجب ان يعني نعمل على قيام
هدنه تسمح بخلق ممرات امنه تسمح للمواطنين
بانهم يقضوا حاجاتهم في الدواء
والعلاج والمستلزمات المعيشه من غذاء الى
اخره الى اخره
ايضا
انا اعتقد انه
ما في بديل
لغيري اننا كسودانيين نقعد
مع بعض في حوار يؤدي
لحل مرضي لكل فئات الشعب السوداني
انا بركز على كلمه حوار
تفاوض مفضي للاتفاق
في تاريخنا القريب انا ايضا
من هذا المنبر
اناشد
وادعو
للرفض اي تدخل اجنبي في الشان السوداني
ولذلك ندعو المجتمع الدولي
يمارس الدور ايجابي لدعم
عوده الحوار السياسي
وايضا اكرر الدعوه
لقياده
الجيش
وقياده الدعم السريع
للجلوس فورا في مفاوضات
تؤدي لمعالجه وحلحله الخلافات التي ادت
لهذا الوضع
ايضا
قبل ان اختم هذه المداخله
ادعو الدول
العربيه
والافريقيه والشغييره
لمسانده الشعب السوداني الذي يمر بظروف
انسانيه صعبه جدا
تتطلب تضافر جهود كل المجتمع الدولي في
هذه المهنه
وفي هذا الاطار
سوف ابذل كل الجهد
للمساعده في هذه العمليه
سوف اقوم باجراء اتصالات
بكل العواصف
لتشجيعهم على التحرك على وجه السرعه
لتقديم كل المساعدات الانسانيه الممكنه
للشعب السوداني ومساعدته في هذه المهنه
اختم بعبارات
زعيمنا الافريقي نيلسون مانديلا
عندما قال
سهل جدا
انك
تهدم وتكسر
الابطال هم من يبنون
ويسمعون السلام
شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات